Speaker 1: A wildly triggered failed former
President Donald Trump. Even before Ron DeSantis
announced that he was running for president,
released an attack ad on Ron DeSantis, calling
him a swamp creature. Let's take a look at this.
This might give us a little bit of a preview of
the sorts of lines of attack that we may be seeing
during what is certainly going to be an extremely
ugly Republican primary campaign. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Trump Defeats 2016. President Trump
defeats the liberals and heads to Washington to
drain the swamp. But swamp creature Ron DeSantis
is about to start his third term in Congress,
and he's already voted repeatedly to cut Social
Security and Medicare. 2017 Trump passes huge
tax cuts for nearly Everyone. And Ron DeSantis,
he's pushing a bill that would swap those
tax cuts for a new 23% national sales tax.
Speaker 1: So let's just pick pick this.
Speaker 2: Families pay more.
Speaker 1: Just to pick. I can't fact check
everything here, but Trump has been saying
this a lot, that Ron DeSantis was going to put
in a 23% sales tax and, you know, make everybody
pay more. The reality is what DeSantis supported
was part of the fair tax proposal. And what that
would have done is put in a 23% national sales
tax, but get rid of income taxes, payroll taxes,
estate taxes and gift taxes. And the idea
was simplify the tax code and make it more
transparent by lowering taxes for rich people.
So is it a lie to say DeSantis supported a 23%
national sales tax? It's not a lie, but it was
a right wing proposal to lower taxes on the
rich. Imagine that you're in the 37% federal tax
bracket and then you've got your Social Security,
Medicare and so on and so forth. If you replace
all of that stuff, if you get rid of income tax,
payroll tax, estate tax and gift tax, and you just
pay 23%, that's a mark on what you spend. That's
an insane decline in taxes on the rich. So, like,
is it a lie? What Trump is saying in the ad, it's
not a lie, but it's extraordinarily deceptive.
Speaker 2: 2018 Trump is building a wall,
securing the border, fighting the invasion.
While Ron DeSantis is voting against funding
for Trump's wall in Washington. One
was a leader and one let us down. Even
DeSantis admitted there are big differences
between him and Trump. Obviously there is,
because I voted contrary to him in the program.
Speaker 1: So this is going to be such an
ugly primary that it's going to make your
head spin. But also a factor will be that
Trump is constantly lying about the Santos.
And if the Santos decides to acknowledge that
Trump is running right, because so far it's
been like, just don't even talk about Trump.
Is he going to tell the truth about
Trump policy or is he going to have
to lie to draw distinctions that don't
really exist? We're going to watch it.